so what are we going to do today so
today we're going to continue with amino
acids peptides and proteins and I'm
going to talk about a different protein
variant that is the causative the cause
of sickle cell anemia and it's a very
interesting structural issue but let me
very briefly recap what we did last time
and then talk to you a little bit about
a process known as denaturation so last
time we discussed how the primary
sequence of a polypeptide chain defines
its folded structure the folded
structure is put in place with secondary
and tertiary interactions non covalent
interactions secondary just between
amongst backbone and its tertiary sort
of everything else even including
backbone omits but either with water or
a side chain and so on and then there
are some proteins that associate into
quaternary structure so these monomer
subunits as they would be called and I'm
gonna depict this as like a closed
circle or an open circle may form dimers
of some kind
the dimers may be heterodimers or they
may be homo dimers or you could form
trimers tetra MERS and so on and when we
talk about hemoglobin which is the
protein that gets that it has a problem
is the cause of sickle cell anemia it
will what you'll see that at is a hetero
tetrameric protein so in this sort of
rendition you kind of draw it like this
where there are four subunits tour of
one flavor and tour of the other and
that's the quaternary structure of
hemoglobin now proteins fold they are
weak forces that are holding them
together but there's a lot of weak
forces but if you subjects a protein to
various treatments that may break up
those weak forces the protein will
undergo a process of denaturation so
anyone think of what kinds of things
would cause protein denaturation yes
heat is a bad WA is a serious one
obviously and heat yes I'll write them
all down
what's your pH so peach acidity basicity
and we'll talk about why those things
cause changes any other thoughts yes oh
yeah so for example salt organic
solvents a process that a lot of people
don't necessarily think about but as
engineers some of you will is shear
forces so if you're shooting a protein
through a very narrow tubing and there's
high shear forces those who are also
denature proteins so with eat it's very
clear you're gonna break those weak
bonds and then they you know they can
either reform or if you go to to high
heat the unfolded protein starts to form
aggregates and anyone who has ever
scrambled an egg knows that that is an
irreversible process you don't get to
cram the egg back into the shell it's
not the same anymore because what you're
doing when you're scrambling eggs is
denaturing proteins through heat
treatment so that's what heat does it
breaks the forces the the proteins
stretch out into their denatured state
and instead of refolding to a compact
structure they just start aggregating
with each other and that's pretty much
your reverse 'fl ph is interesting why
would pH break up a low temperature why
would pH cause changes yeah
okay so pH perfect so pH will change the
charge state of many of your site chains
and once you've changed it you might
have had a lovely electrostatic
interaction but then you go and
protonate the carboxylic acid and it
can't fall in fact it wants the former
it wants to break a partisan as opposed
to come together so that is changing
charge state which causes denaturation
salts and organics for example they make
interactions with parts of the protein
for example organics organic molecules
may slip into a hydrophobic core and
break them up just push them apart they
want to be there and then too many too
much of a high concentration of an
organic solvent that is miscible with
water and we would say ethanol Osito
nitrile DMSO but you don't need to worry
about too much of which details well
actually once you get above 10 percent
or so we'll just start denaturing
proteins sometimes reversibly but often
irreversibly so this is very important
to know the proteins are stable but you
got to treat them nicely there are some
human diseases that are a result of Mis
folded or aggregated proteins so for
example all the prion diseases are
proteins gone bad pretty much where they
not in a folded structure anymore but
they are in aggregates that cause
problems with cellular processes and
toxicity so Alzheimer's disease mad cow
disease a lot of those neurologic
disorders caused by poorly folded or
very miss folded proteins for examples
so these are the things we talked about
last time with respect to the flux from
primary to secondary to tertiary to
quaternary and that's a perfect time for
me to introduce to you what we'll talk
about today so last time we talked about
structural proteins and I showed you how
collagen just with a simple defect
changing a glycine to an alanine in one
of its subunits really alters the
tertiary the quaternary structure
the protein to make very weak collagen
that's no longer supportive of bone
strength but what I'm going to talk to
you about today is a defect in a
transport protein that carries oxygen
around the body so we're gonna talk
about hemoglobin these diseases are what
are known as inborn errors of metabolism
or that's kind of a complex term or
genetically linked diseases because
there is a single defect in a DNA strand
that then gets transcribed into an RNA
strand so one base defect that then
becomes an amino acid defect in your
protein strand so these are tiny changes
in the protein of the cause dramatic
changes in the structure and function of
the protein and what you will see with
hemoglobin is it causes a real problem
with the quaternary structure and then
causes proteins to aggregate so
hemoglobin is the dominant protein in
red blood cells or erythrocytes
and in fact the differentiation of the
red blood cell as it comes from
progenitor cells goes through a process
where the red blood cell dumps out its
nucleus so it can't divide anymore and
basically the content of the cell is
extremely high in hemoglobin you've
packed the hemoglobin into the red blood
cell at the cost of losing the nucleus
so that's terminally differentiated
can't become a red blood cell and can't
divide anymore and it has about a half
life they have about a half life 100
days so they turn over and then that's
it and when red blood cells turn over
the hemoglobin has to be taken care of
in order that is not toxic red blood
cells are red because of a particular
molecule that's in the hemoglobin
called ahima molecule which is bound to
iron which provides the hemoglobin with
the capacity to pick up oxygen in your
lungs travel it around the body and then
leave it where it's needed and then
replace the oxygen with co2 and take the
co2 back to the lungs in order for you
to respire it out okay so he made the
team aglow beam carries oxygen and co2
from oxygen from the lungs co2 back to
the lungs and the reason why you need
the iron is that the iron is coordinated
to the oxygen so the heme molecule I
won't draw it if you want to see it it's
a big complex organic structure a very
interesting structure but something for
another day here look but I want to
stress to you that the iron heme complex
is red that's why your blood cells are
red your blood cells don't have a
nucleus so they can cram in lots more
hemoglobin so it's kind of a fascinating
situations so hemoglobin is an example
of a homo tetrameric protein and it has
four subunits two of one flavor and two
of another so we call this an alpha 2
beta 2 protein differentiating the alpha
subunits and the beat ones yes why isn't
it homo tetrameric this you could ask
why is it I don't know I mean there will
be interactions amongst the subunits
that favor that particular packaging the
subunits are kind of similar in shape
they have what's called a globe in fold
you could more or less pick out those
tubes remember our alpha helixes they
could form tetramers that are all the
same but the energetically favored form
is the two and two hemoglobin is a
tetrameric protein because that's really
advantageous for picking up
Sigyn and dropping off oxygen in a very
narrow oxygen range so there are
proteins called globins that just one of
these that can bind oxygen hemoglobin is
tetrameric because it has a cooperative
oxygen binding so in a very narrow range
of oxygen it fills all four sites in the
tetrameric protein with an oxygen
molecule so it's very advantageous in
from a physics perspective that it
responds to very narrow changes in
oxygen does that make sense to everyone
yeah okay it means cut anything that's
cooperative means that one let's say
I've got a tetramer of hemoglobin one
oxygen binds to one of them so I'm a
binding oxygen here and then binding to
the next the next and the next gets
easier and easier so it's they sort of
want to come in as a team and that's
handy for maximizing oxygen transport
around the body in a narrow oxygen range
which we can only deal with what's out
there in the atmosphere so we have to
make this work does that answer your
question okay all right so where was I
okay so so what we're gonna do today
we're gonna look at hemoglobin
it's the tetra mer those discoid
structures are the heme that I just
mentioned I've drawn them as this sort
of four leaf clover here just for
simplicity and there is a single defect
in the sequence of the single monomer
subunits in hemoglobin so each of these
so there are four proteins betta globin
two copies of beta globin and two copies
of alpha globin they are all let me see
what's the size did you deluded it to
pretty subjective you know I could never
see things when I'm up at the screen but
they're about 160 156 okay so they're
about 146 amino acids long in each of
them and a single defect in a beta
globin where you have a change from
glutamic acid residue 6 to valine
residue 6 one change in beta globin
which means two changes in the whole
structure because there are two beta
globin alters the properties of the
hemoglobin and causes what's called
sickling of your red blood cells so
let's take a look at what that would
look like at the amino acid level
glutamic acid is one of your charged
amino acids I'm just going to draw a
little bit of it as it were in a peptide
and it's at position six in the sequence
so it's six residues from the amino
terminus because we always write things
in this direction and the change takes
place to put in place a valine and
there's a pretty big change in identity
and personality of those residues you've
gone from polar charged to neutral big
fluffy hydrophobic residue and it's
really amazing so the beta globin is
expressed on chromosome 11 it's a
hundred and thirty-four million base
pairs one base is changed so what you
have in the DNA in the normal DNA that
encodes the No
more beta-globin gene there's a
particular sequence of nucleic acids
this is what the double strand would
look like we're gonna see way more about
nucleic acids next week when that gets
converted to the messenger RNA you get a
particular code that in the genetic code
codes for glutamic acids everything's
normal a single change if we change the
center nucleic acid within the DNA it
makes a different messenger RNA and one
base pair puts in valine instead of
glutamic acid out of a hundred and
thirty-four million base pairs so what
happens in the normal normal hemoglobin
you have normal behavior you have this
tetrameric structure false commits
cooperativity carries oxygen it moves
around the blood low problem excuse me
it sits in the erythrocytes or red blood
cells no problem the minute you have
that mutation the hemoglobin molecules
start to associate into clusters like
fiber lacrosse thus because each tetra
mer gets glued to another tetra mer and
another one and another one so you have
hemoglobin not behaving as this
beautiful independent quaternary
structure but rather sticking to
physically sticking to other molecules
and those tangles get those molecules
get so so large that they start to form
long and inflexible chains and it's such
a dramatic change that that discoid
structure you're that you're familiar
with for red blood cells suddenly
becomes a sickle shape so that would be
the normal cell with normal hemoglobin
but sickle cell they look like this
they're kind of curved odd a very odd
shape and the problem is red blood cells
that have evolved to move really
smoothly through your capillaries as
soon as you get a different shape that's
sort of you know not that discoid
structure they start clogging in the
capillaries and when you have the defect
where all of your hemoglobin is messed
up with this variation it's incredibly
painful because think of all your
capillary
is going out to the Father reaches of
your joints there is thin blood vessels
blocked up with the sick old red blood
cells that are caused by the variation
in hemoglobin so that one little defect
takes us all the way to a serious
disease all right so what I want to do
very briefly is show you the molecular
basis for this all right and the defect
actually appears on the two beta globin
chains but right on the outside of the
protein not in the middle of the protein
because this is a defect that affects
how proteins interact with other
proteins not the function of the protein
on its own probably still carries oxygen
just fine but it's the mechanical change
in the hemoglobin that causes the
disease
okay so sickle cell anemia the
hemoglobin is now called hemoglobin s
with that mutation that I just described
and when people have a heterozygous it
means they have one good copy of the
gene that's normal and the copy of the
gene that's the variant and you'll learn
much more about this in human genetics
when we talk about that later on so you
have a lecture of the okay hemoglobin
and the bad and the sickle cell
hemoglobin people who are homozygous for
the defect all of their hemoglobin is is
disrupted and those are the people who
really end up in hospital with a lot of
transfusions and so on
the heterozygous actually you can manage
quite well with and I'm going to show
you in a minute that in some parts of
the world being heterozygous I having
some of your hemoglobin with the defect
and some without it actually comes with
an advantage it's a really cool story
okay so what I'm going to do is quickly
show you the wire structure okay so this
is the structure that elucidated the
real reason for this for the the
interaction what happens when you have
this mutation okay and it was a
structure that was captured of a dimer
of hemoglobin molecules where you
really see what was happening at the
interface and the sorts of changes that
have been put in place by that variation
from the charged to the neutral
structure so for any of you who want to
pop by I can start to show you how to
manipulate pi mol we can do that
separately from class but this is a
dimer of tetramers and if I just show
you just some of the subunits I can
actually show you how there's two of
each subunit in each structure so if I
go I can pick some out every other 1g
and then I can color them a different
color you can see where the globins
where the beta globin czar and where the
alpha globin czar that still looks like
chicken wire it's very unsatisfactory so
what I can do is I can show you
everything as a cartoon and get rid of
all those little lines and then you can
see perfectly the to the structure where
you see two beta globin z' and two alpha
globin x' in each structure okay so what
we're gonna do next is zoom in to see
what's happening where we've done this
mutation what's going on with the
placement of the baleen in that
structure all right and wherever I put a
fork four letter code so that one was
two HBS that's what's known as the
protein databank code and it enables you
to go fetch the coordinates of that
protein so if any of you for the late
project want to do a protein structure
and print it come to me and I'll explain
a lot more about that or all the TAS can
also do that so let me now move you to
looking in closely to the variations so
what I've done here is I've actually
colored the beta globin spurple and the
Alpha globin is a cyan colored you can
see the hems in each of the subunits
those are those red wire things and now
we've zoomed in to the place where the
mutation is where you have a baleen
instead of a carboxylic acid
and what you can see from this image
which should stop is that the baleen on
one subunit in one homo tetramer
interacts with a sticky patch on another
subunit that's made up of phenylalanine
85 in the adjacent protein and leucine
88 in the adjacent protein so this
sticky patch on one surface glues on to
a sticky patch on the surface of another
tetra mer if you had glutamic glutamate
there would that form no in fact it
would be quite deterred from forming
because you don't want to cram that
negatively charged element into those
two hydrophobic residues so what you've
gone from is a situation where this
really is fine on a surface it's
hydrated it's not sticking to anything
to another situation where you have
phenylalanine and leucine which are both
hydrophobic providing a catch on the one
tetramer where the the valine from the
other tetramer combined and because the
molecules are tetra mer on each of the
subunits there is also another valine
that will go off and do that elsewhere
and another valine and there's one you
can't see that's tucked behind so that's
why the hemoglobin forms these
structures because every hemoglobin
molecule has two places to stick to
another hemoglobin tetra mer and so on
so think of the repercussions from one
nucleic acid change that's really quite
remarkable so what we've seen here is
that that change occurs so just just a
couple of moments for you to think about
this you can have variations at that
site that won't cause a problem which
ones of these do you think at least
likely to cause a sickle cell type of
phenomenon so tyrosine serine aspartic
acid and lysine so I'm going to change
the glutamate to something else which
one's going to have a perfectly normal
hemoglobin there's one that stands out
yeah aspartic that's fine no problem it
just switched it for her it's younger
brother wait which one of the others and
and in many cases here you could
probably argue your way to all of them
but one would be pretty bad which one
would be pretty bad
tyrosine exactly it's another even
though it's got that Oh H group it's
still pretty hydrophobic because of that
ring system there what about the other
two serine and lysine what do you think
which one would probably be in fact the
least detrimental of those remaining two
and give me the reason as well yes
lysine I think it would be lysine
because lysine is now positively charged
it's equally unlikely to want to do this
goofy interaction because it is also
charged just charged in the other
direction but one could also argue that
serine would be okay
because it's got it's a little bit more
not a polar so it wouldn't cause as much
problem okay
finally the this issue with sickle cell
anemia there's some fascinating data
that shows in parts of the world for
example during a drug trial for
Plasmodium falciparum one of the
causative agents of malaria they found
that one out of 15 people with the
sickle-cell trait was infected with
malaria whereas the the people who were
healthy normal homozygous for the right
hemoglobin 14 out of 15 were infected
with Plasmodium falciparum and now what
do you think why do you think that is
how can we relate the infectivity of a
parasite with the shape of a cell we've
gone from these juicy looking red blood
cells nice and round and probably quite
open to a cell that sort of difficult
shape so it turns out that the parasite
doesn't want to infect the sickle cells
that cells red blood cells anywhere near
as well and there are for example other
Bloods tested which shows the same
correlation
and here's a map of Africa where you see
a massive overlap of the prevalence of
the sickle cell trait and the and the
presence of Plasmodium falciparum so
there's there's there is a evolutionary
advantage to having the heterozygous
variant where you have some normal
hemoglobin but some of the sickling
hemoglobin because it confers you some
resistance to term to malaria it's not
good to have both of them the variant
that causes sickling because that's
painful and it really causes a lot of
health disorders it's just when you have
one of each gene encoding both variants
okay all right great okay so now we're
gonna talk about enzymes and these are
the proteins that catalyze reactions any
questions about that so while a lot of
disease states actually might be bred
out because someone would have be at a
disadvantage
with a particular disease in this case
that trait has been maintained because
it offers a very different advantage
with respect to disease okay let's talk
about enzymes for a moment all for the
rest of the class in fact okay so
enzymes are the heavy lifters of the
protein world because they catalyze all
the reactions in metabolism in
biosynthesis all kinds of
transformations that make you what you
are enzymes a protein based catalysts
you will know that writing again there
were a couple of other terms I just
quickly want to give you so an enzyme
there's also a term known as an ISO xym
and an allison you may see them you'll
see Alice
less commonly but you'll see Isis I'm
quite commonly an Isis I'm of one enzyme
is a variation on the enzyme that
catalyzes the same reaction but it's
expressed on a different gene an aloes
I'm is the same enzyme but with a
variation in it so it's it's encoded by
an allele of one gene so there it's just
a variation of the gene that might have
happened through a mutation still
catalyzes the reaction but there's a
change in slight change in the sequence
but they're coded by the same gene same
gene with a variation and as I said you
will see the isozyme term more commonly
than the al Azim term now why do we need
enzymes well the problem is there are
reactions physiologic reactions that we
need to carry out that are just too hard
to carry out at room temperature pH 7 in
water they just don't occur so you need
enzyme catalysis for all of your
metabolic reactions let me just give you
one trivial example this bond really no
nicely now peptide or amide bond if I
want to hydrolyze that if I want to
break it open pH 7 physiologic
temperatures so 37 see you know in water
it would take me how many years is it
the half-life of that bond would be 600
years okay there and that's pretty
untenable for digesting a Big Mac even
even under the best of circumstances
right so we
need enzymes to speed up breaking down
proteins carrying out reactions because
otherwise we just can't we can't do
anything so what I want to describe to
you some of the details of how enzymes
work and then how we can control the
function of enzymes so typical enzymes
take a substrate to a product some
enzymes may take two substrates and make
one product some enzymes may we take one
substrate and make two products it just
depends on the transformation that
you're doing enzymes are classified into
a bunch of different families but the
thing that will tell you that something
you're reading about is an enzyme is the
suffix a s e at the end of the name of
the enzyme so the enzyme that hydrolyzes
the peptide bond or hydrolyzes proteins
is called no big surprise a protease and
you'll see later on ribonuclease DNA's
oxidoreductases all kinds of rare
reactions where if you see this term at
the end of the name it's telling you
quite loud and clear that it's an enzyme
it's just a very sort of simple way of
remembering now now enzymes promote
promote reactions
in order that we can have them carried
out at room temperature but we want to
think about how they they carry out
these changes and transformations what
is it about the structure of the protein
that enables these reactions but the
first thing we have to do is take a look
and the thermodynamics and kinetics of a
transformation so before I go anywhere
what I want to do is describe to you how
enzymes work by thinking about the
physical parameters that we describe the
energetics of a transformation so in in
thermodynamics you'll know Delta G is
Delta H minus T Delta s and we're really
only gonna worry about one of these
terms we're gonna worry about Delta G
and I'll explain why so Delta G is the
Gibbs free energy H is the enthalpy T is
the temperature in Kelvin and then s is
entropy so these are two terms when
you're looking at an energy diagram we
generally think about reactions where we
describe the y coordinate as the change
in Delta G the change in the free energy
and the x coordinate is your reaction
coordinate so in going from a substrate
to a product we generally have a
situation where we have a substrate at a
certain energy and then maybe a product
at a different energy and we're going to
talk about the details of that so why do
we deal with Gibbs free energy not an
enthalpy does anyone know okay
enthalpy describes the energies of
all the bonds in a molecule but when
you're doing an enzyme catalyzed
transformation you're not busting open
all of those bonds you're not breaking
something down to carbon hydrogen and
oxygen you're only dealing with parts of
the energetics of the molecule you're
only dealing with what's known as the
free energy changes to look at the
enthalpy changes isn't going to get you
very far it's not going to describe the
reaction because the enthalpy changes
would be enormous breaking down that
molecule and that's not what you want to
achieve in a chemical transformation we
care about Delta G now the next thing to
think about is what are the energetics
of the reaction and how does an enzyme
catalyzed reaction manipulate those n
energetics so the key thing here is we
want to talk about Gibbs free energy
shouldn't written quite this much stuff
here because I need the blackboard
alright so when you describe a reaction
you want to understand how far that
reaction goes and how fast that reaction
goes so when you go through a reaction
we can describe how far the reaction
goes by thinking about the free energy
of the substrates and the products so in
this case the substrate is at a higher
energy than the products so you will go
a long way through the reaction to make
mud quite a lot of product in there in a
transformation so that describes how far
the reaction goes so that is the
difference between the energy of the
substrate and the product how fast the
reaction goes concern is described in
and didn't different part of this
diagram does anyone know what it is yes
yes exactly how fast the reaction goes
is literally how high the mountain is
but you have to get over
to carry out the transformation and that
height is described as the energy of
activation so that tells you how fast
and the difference here tells you how
far the energy of activation is a really
important parameter because it's
actually what gets manipulated when
you're dealing with catalyzed reactions
so the energy of activation the higher
that mountain is the slower the reaction
will be because it's a much harder
transformation to go through the
reactions in our bodies can be of
different flavors depending on the
difference in energy of the substrate
and the product so shown there substrate
going to products where the product is
at lower energy than the substrate we
would call this an exergonic reaction
because we're releasing energy in the in
the transformation so as higher than P
exergonic and if we have a different
reaction and I'll sketch this one in
here where the product is higher energy
and this is a reaction coordinate then
that will be an endergonic reaction both
reactions happen in the enzyme catalyzed
systems and we'll explain why you're
able to catalyze even ones that require
energy so exergonic releases energy
and endergonic requires okay what else
have I got on here we also in the
situations where energy is produced the
exergonic reactions we call these
catabolic processes and if you have
trouble remembering catabolic and
anabolic just join me in that because I
always forget which is which but the
ones that produce energy a catabolic the
ones that require energy are anabolic
and when we think about metabolism the
catabolic reactions are when we're
breaking molecules down because we need
energy we need to use it to do something
the anabolic reactions are when we want
to store things store fats build
proteins because they're going to be
endergonic they're going to be requiring
energy to take place
I just forgot one thing that I learned
shamefully done
remember this axis is kilocalories per
mole most commonly when we're talking
about Delta G or kilo joules per mole if
you're in a different part of the world
but it's important to have units on
these diagrams so that tells us a little
bit about enzyme catalyzed reactions we
need the enzyme to do something about
this energy of activation because if we
didn't have a high energy of activation
I brought a Snickers bar to eat during
class which is burst into flames right
it has it needs a high energy of
activation to keep it stable regularly
in under regular conditions but only
break down the bonds under time at times
when you require that break down right
all right so what are the catalysts do
okay now I've shown you the simple
reaction the enzyme is a very large
structure it binds to a substrate
chemistry happens and it releases a
product but at the same time you can't
disobey the principles of thermodynamics
so there's certain criteria we have to
think about when we consider an enzyme
catalyzed reaction so first of all do
not disobey whichever law of
thermodynamics is is they do not change
Delta G Delta G is a property of the two
reactants you're not going to change it
with a catalyst it's it's going to have
a much more important impact on a
different parameter which parameter do
enzymes change and help lower over there
right so catalysts do to change and in
fact lower energy of activation and
we'll talk about how they do that at the
end and then the last rule about a
catalyst is you can recover them
unchanged after a reaction it would be a
lousy catalyst if it did it's chemistry
and then you've used up the catalysts so
enzyme catalysts are the ultimate green
reagents you can keep using them
thousands and thousands of times to
continuously turn over transformations
so you haven't changed a catalyst so the
things that we want to think about is
how what are the processes that that
enzymes can manipulate and I should
probably just quickly run through these
slides so we've talked about these
entities but I put them on the board
because they're particularly important
so the energy of activation of a
catalyzed reaction is lower than the
uncatalyzed
not going to bore you with these
questions because you can work this out
quite readily so delta g is the free
energy that changes and these are
endergonic because the energy of the
products is lower so this is the slide I
want to get to with respect to the
enzyme to enzyme catalyst so we always
think well gosh the enzyme is really
large relative to the size of the
product that's because all that energy
within the protein folded structure is
very useful for lowering the energy of
activation of our transformations so
let's say I have a reaction that
involves two substrates coming together
to make a product right if I'm off the
enzyme these guys it's gonna take them a
long time to bump into each other to do
chemistry the way enzymes catalyze those
types of reactions is they have binding
sites for both of those compounds in
fact the enzyme acts as a stage 1
substrate binds the other substrate
binds their binding close to each other
on the enzyme chemistry can happen it
favors reactions that involve multiple
molecules what about another situation
where you have a bond for example the
amide bond the protease is break it's
hard to think of how that how can we
make that more easy
well amides are most stable when they
are flat and planar through this
arrangement of atoms but what can happen
on the enzyme is that they can twist
bonds to make them less stable and then
more easy to hydrolyze
so the structure of that enzyme
basically holds on to the substrate and
twists or distorts the bond that you're
trying to do chemistry on to once again
lower the energy of activation another
way enzymes work is in a reaction where
you're breaking this bond you might make
charged intermediates the enzymes there
to hold those charged intermediates in
order to stabilize them once again to
lower energy of activation so it's funny
when you get the question that's well
how do enzymes catalyze RIA
actions there is no one rule you want to
think about the reactions and then just
think about the ways in which an enzyme
could contribute to that
for example orienting to substrates
ready to do chemistry causing physical
strain in a bond that you want to break
or comforting electric charges as
charges that form during a reaction
coordinate so their loads and loads of
different principles and it's a really
important study that's carried that is
carried out so finally and I think I
have a couple you know I have a couple
of minutes but I want to just describe
this to you it'll also be covered in the
sections because I'm going to rush it a
bit because this last bit is features a
little bit on that on the pset so
finally we've enzymes are very commonly
the targets of drugs we like to think
that some drugs are important targets if
we deactivate the enzyme we might
mitigate the symptoms of a disease now
you can't go in and heat the enzyme or
you know denature the enzyme if you're
trying to treat a person so we do a lot
of work to mitigate disease by
inhibiting enzymes with small molecules
so in these slides I described to you
the types of molecules that may alter
the chemistry of a transformation so if
a substrate binds to an enzyme active
site we often do this pac-man rendition
you could design a molecule that binds
there instead and basically inhibits the
substrate from getting there this would
be called a simple reversible inhibitor
that's competitive with the active site
there are other inhibitors that will
bind to the enzyme but do chemistry with
it and stay blocked at the enzyme and
that would be called an irreversible
competitive inhibitor you can't get the
inhibitor off and there's differences in
the way you can reverse this because for
example up here if I add a lot more
substrate and these are equilibria I can
get my reaction to happen anyway but
here I could add as much substrate as
possible but it won't help it won't
reverse the transformer
okay and there's a question here to
restore the reaction the answer really
is you just have to start with new
enzyme because you've covalently changed
the protein structure the last type of
inhibitors that are important the ones
that bind at different sites on the
enzymes and they are called allosteric
allo always means different so if you
have a compound that's an allosteric
inhibitor it might bind on another face
of the enzyme but it'll alter the active
sites so it doesn't work that's an
allosteric inhibitor and the final type
of compound is an allosteric activator
that may bind somewhere else on the
enzyme but make it more active so these
are the way small molecules work I'd
like to encourage the TAS to just cover
this in a little bit more detail because
I brushed it and I'll also remain it at
the beginning of the next class but bear
in mind we should have everything
covered now for the problem set one and
if you have any questions reach out to
us cover them in section and I'll
reiterate a little bit of this in the
next class and finally there's a little
bit of reading if you would like to
prepare we'll talk about carbohydrates
next time one of my favorite molecules
and there's also a fabulous set of
videos on how enzymes work and the
protein databank a site and you will see
this little handout on the slides
version of the slides that's posted
you